we got this one from NDTV I see this
story popping popping up all over the
place man tests positive for MERS
Coronavirus in Abu Dhabi says World
World Health Organization a 28 year old
man it says a positive for a potentially
fatal Middle Eastern respiratory
syndrome coronavirus now here's the
thing MERS has been around for a while
right they say what is it um it's been
recorded in 27 countries since 2012 over
the time 2605 cases and 936 Associated
deaths have been reported here's what I
want to say about this a lot of people
are suggesting this could be the
Catalyst for another lockdown as
elections are looming I don't think so
MERS has been around before it doesn't
spread like kovid did kovid was novel
but they're calling it MERS Dash COV
that's the freaky thing that's what I'm
seeing a bunch of these stories do
because now they're associating MERS
with kovid yeah that could be a
political Catalyst for giving the
government power to do whatever they
want I think I saw there was a 25 death
it kills like 30 percent of the people
in 36 36 so that's nothing like covert
that's something where like you get it
either survive it or you die
uh and it's not really that I don't know
if how transmissible it is one in three
sorry Dave were you about to say
something no no it just sounds like they
added three letters to MERS exactly
because now they're associating the
pandemic the lockdown the sickness with
something that they can say has a 36
mortality rate despite the fact it does
not spread nearly as as horrifically but
could be enough for politicians to say
hey MERS see MERS kovid is here
we need lockdowns we need mail-in voting
the mortality rate is 36 percent oh boy
here we go again yeah I do feel like
they feel like covet has uh worn out you
know they've been saying for a while
they had all the the variants and at a
certain point they were like seems like
people aren't going to stay at home no
matter what and now we have the malaria
outbreaks which malaria can be really
serious but it is interesting that
there's almost at times if I'm if I'm
cynical feels like they're just trying
to test out what will scare you enough
to go home oh I think they are though I
mean and with this it's I I don't think
you can have another coveted lockdown
because everybody's just gonna go yeah
no I'm not going to do that at all I I
don't know if I agree with that do you
think they will some people maybe but I
I don't think the majority were still
calling for it you still have prominent
liberal person
saying yeah yeah
we put it out just recently I got locked
down again yeah I said something like
that yeah he was he's the worst
Professor Peter's MD PhD he's terrible
yeah he's didn't he write a book called
vaccines and give my daughters autism I
did from junk food he was like Glee
telling Joe Rogan that he feeds his
autistic daughter junk food yeah
like in blame it's insane that yeah that
guy is a he's just worthless
but was wasn't he just saying recently
something about like Nina I'm looking at
his Twitter I can't find it oh it was
the post Barbie yeah in this post Barbie
world let's not forget I'm I'm nervous
about coming over as long as everyone's
go to the movies so he was like oh but
no one's masking anymore no one's doing
tests anymore I think that was the Tweet
right yeah it was something like that
the movies are so popular we have to
worry about another rise in covid
basically which is also like a typical
like don't go have fun I'm holier than
you for have noticing notice this I'm
protecting you all with my my great
ideas we have anonymous sex apps and
we're worried about people going to the
movies it's absurd go to the movies
bring a wipe if you want with you but
haven't we already proven that putting
on a mask with Dirty Fingers isn't going
to help you all that much
oh my gosh I don't know especially like
are we allowed to say that I don't know
100 yeah if you're rebreathing like
fecal matter in your mask
you put it in your bag or your coat
pocket like bad things here's here's a
tweet dirty underwear it's the same
sorry no no I just want to pull the
Tweet uh Peter said not to be a Debbie
Downer but anyone worried about a post
Barbie box office coveted bump or post
Opie we'll net we'll probably never know
since no one seems to be keeping track
of such things anymore keep up with your
boosters and find a pink n95 or KN 95 if
you can
and he's just talking about the box
office for these two movies now I don't
know if that really matters but I I do
want to stress this is this is my point
these people are still calling for these
things to happen again
yo there were a lot of places where
people did not follow the protocols yeah
I didn't but there were a lot of places
that did to an extreme degree absolutely
and there was enforcement of these
things to ridiculous degrees so I don't
think it's an issue of whether people
want or don't want something because
they let it happen in the first place
and local cops and Sheriff's Department
went and arrested Cafe owners and salon
owners the cops will do as they're told
a lot of those things are hard once they
get started they're easier to stop from
happening once it gets rolling then
you're like especially as a cop you're
like well got there to put it into place
now I've got to kind of do my job and
enforce the dumb rule that got put into
place but if you don't let them put the
rule into place in the first place but
this also had though a lot of cops
though the new business owners that were
like you know what you don't have to
build your restaurant outside it's fine
you have a speakeasy now I mean there
were a lot of places in this country who
didn't deal with it you know I mean you
can't I guess legally you can't say that
or have a statistic on it speakers
existed in in prohibition of course and
there were cops who would look the other
way and things like that but
I'm not saying it was the majority
unfortunately you are right I think what
happens is the fragmentation of
community and the family and partly due
to the internet what do they do in New
Jersey with atelis gym they brought the
local cops didn't do what the city
wanted so they got cops from a different
Suburban town to come in and enforce the
law here's the crazy thing about all
that why would any Community accept
external police
coming into their Community to enforce
rules their Community does not agree
with is the crazy thing but is the proof
to what I'm talking about yep irrational
fear they had to bring in state troopers
into New York because a lot of NYPD guys
didn't want to enforce these rules like
shut down bars and stuff so they bring
in a different uh agency now they can
understand the hierarchy of law
enforcement State Police have different
jurisdiction they have more jurisdiction
but the idea that there are two cities
let's call it city city city town and
town city CityVille in the village of
cities Town whatever and uh
one City's like we want to force
everyone in their homes but they're
refusing and the cops won't enforce it
let's bring in cops from a different
town why would anyone in the community
be like we certainly respect this uh
this Police Department with no
jurisdiction in our town but they did
that's the point yes they did I guess my
point is how do we continue making a
living in this country how do we not
keep everybody from going completely
impoverished how do we keep any brick
and mortar business going any restaurant
running anything really working that's
not just a giant Corporation where you
work in a warehouse wearing a mask all
day sweating I mean really what what's
the end game I mean it does go at a lot
of this x stuff we were talking about
and going into that sort of Bleak future
but why why wouldn't we fight against
that I think that question is a good
question for Peter Hotes and people like
Peter hotez that made tons of money and
became super well known during the
pandemic because of the pandemic if that
guy has everything to gain from seeing
another pandemic the way he made out
during covet without it he becomes
irrelevant yeah yep think about how many
people
are sitting there thinking all these
doctors they're like oh man I'd love I
mean fauci's on a TV anymore right well
no the once people found him to be a
slight bit Shady they had to finally you
know kind of push him to the side they
put MSNBC he didn't push him aside for
being shady well no they don't care they
they held big umbrellas with his face on
it and twirled around on was it Jimmy
Kimmel or something or Colbert or
whatever oh yeah the dancing needles he
didn't get booted from TV because he was
shady because covet's not relevant
anymore so they don't need him people
like that they're salivated the idea of
locking down again because it keeps them
in the news and it gives them power of
course they love power yeah that's what
a large part of it is is power and
that's the problem is if if you're
supposed to be somebody who's out there
protecting the public and all you do is
hurt people why would anybody believe
you anymore I don't understand the logic
now I do agree people are dumb I mean
not even dumb they're they're scared and
they are definitely going to believe
things and they're going to be gullible
and they're going to do anything to
protect their families but how much more
evidence do you need that didn't work
I with I have a theory with fauci I
think that he really believed he was
helping people and he was being used by
the pharmaceutical industry to sell
Pharma drugs for profit they're like
let's just find a guy that's obsessed
with public health because I try to
picture fauci being in a background be
like we're gonna make so much money on
this but I just don't see it and that's
why people liked him the amount of
people that did because he truly
believed what he was saying like they're
gonna help you you're gonna get the
thing it's gonna be great you're gonna
be fine wear two masks and everyone's
like he believes it so I believe him
isn't he the highest paid government
employee though he was he was he makes
he was making tons of money he has the
biggest pension or maybe not anymore but
to me it's hard to believe that this guy
isn't aware of money especially when he
signed up to do a documentary with
Disney I mean like yeah I made AIDS
worse and not throw like a girl there is
a desire to have attention and be famous
there I think money the desire to be
compensated and paid is part of that
yeah and it's almost irrelevant to Muse
about what his intentions were yeah
we'll never know but he did make a lot
of money I would imagine it comes on the
show and he became very that would be
awesome when they were pumping out that
documentary whether like you know the
human trafficking one just keeps that
one shelf let's make sure everybody
finds out about how great fauci is just
recently yeah oh I didn't see it what's
it called uh the sound of freedom
I was talking about the factory dock oh
no there was the one on Disney plus oh
yeah they they shelved sound of freedom
and now it's a sleeper hit yep makes 125
million so far yeah yeah
and now with the the smear from the left
is uh these Outlets is that no one's
actually seeing the movie
that in reality they're just paying for
tickets but no one actually is seeing it
well you can pay it forward you're so
desperate that's that's like a terrible
argument you can literally buy tickets
from scanning at the end of the movie
and people are buying them so let's say
they're not then people are still buying
those tickets I bought a thousand
dollars worth of them just to give them
away yeah Pay It Forward thing thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time